well let's bring you more on some other
breaking news now and a senior Nigerian
politician has been found guilty of an
organ harvesting plot involving a
British Hospital
the 60 year old the Nigerian Senator Ike
eguera Madu was one of those found
guilty at the old bayley today
that was along with his 56 year old wife
Beatrice
and a medical middleman Dr obinaw beta
from Southwick in South London
their daughter Sonia however was cleared
after the court deliberated for almost
14 hours and she'll be seen here sitting
next to the 21 year old victim following
that verdict it's the first time
defendants have been convicted under the
modern slavery Act of an organ
harvesting conspiracy
all right well let's get more on this
now with our correspondent Matthew
Thompson just explain this one to us
Matthew
um any it is an extraordinary story
whichever way you look at it isn't it I
mean EK
um is a very prominent man he's a
Nigerian Senator he's a very wealthy man
he has an address in North West London
instantly in Wilson green and he's been
convicted along with his wife Beatrice
and as you say a medical middle man of
what effectively amounts to an Oregon
trafficking plot in which they tried to
bring a 21 year old man to the UK to
exploit him for his kidney it's the
first case of its kind under UK modern
slavery law and essentially what has
happened is that this 21 year old man
was a street Trader in Lagos he was
earning pittance a day pounds really
selling mobile phone accessories from a
wheelbarrow and he was brought to the UK
the court heard to provide a kidney for
the acquire manager's daughter Sonia who
has a debilitating illness she
incidentally was cleared of the same
charges today but this man was offered
the court heard seven thousand pounds
and promised a new life in the UK but it
was never made entirely clear to him or
at least he never fully understood
exactly why he was coming and the first
he find out that it was essentially for
his kidneys was when he turned up at the
Royal free hospital in London to meet
doctors a consultant there said that he
was clearly clearly had a limited
understanding of why he was there and
seemed visibly relieved when ultimately
he was told the surgery wouldn't go
ahead and doctors declined to perform it
at that point he went back to a an
apartment in southern in South London
where he'd been being put up and he told
police that at that moment the mood
changed and he was treated as a slave
until eventually he managed to escape
and run away he slept rough for a few
nights before handing himself into a
police station in Surrey where he said
he had no idea where he was he begged
them to to save his life that prompted
the investigation which led to the
arrests which has brought us to today in
the sentencing of the three defendants
will take place on the 5th of May
okay Matthew thank you